des missiles de croisière russe tiré
depuis la mer noire d'après moscou un
entrepôt situé à churchill dans l'ouest
de l'ukraine a été détruit il aurait
contenu des systèmes de missiles
antichars et de défense aérienne des
armes fournies par les états unis et
certains pays européens
si l'ouest du pays reste encore
relativement épargné à l'est l'offensive
s'intensifie depuis plusieurs jours les
russes bombarde sans répit severodonetsk
contrôler la ville ouvrirait à moscou la
route de cramât torse qu une étape
essentielle pour prendre la région du
dombass selon les autorités ukrainiennes
les russes contrôlerait près de 70% de
la ville l'armée bute toujours sur la
zone industrielle d'azoté severodonezk
n'est pas à 100% libérer les militaires
du rena les militaires des bataillons
nationalistes ukrainiens reste encore
dans la zone industrielle de l'usiné
azote
si la majorité de la population a fui le
dombass certains civils sont restés dans
les villages le long de la ligne de
front
où je vis dans ma maison ce qui arrive
est la volonté de dieu la prise de
partir laissons jeunes
dans le sud un nicolas yves des signes
de résistance ukrainienne l'armée russe
vient d'être arrêtée aux abords de la
ville et les combats se transforme en
guerre de tranchées pour y faire face le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
réclame à ses alliés occidentaux de
nouvelles armes plus puissantes